Valentina was pregnant when her husband
went missing just after the start of the
war now their daughter elizaveta has
turned one and has yet to see her
father but Valentina is convinced he is
alive after seeing what appeared to be
his photo on Russian social
media I was sure that my husband was in
captivity because when we last spoke he
said he would do everything to return to
me and our baby along with other
families she attends regular sessions at
an organization trying to find out the
fate of missing soldiers we working with
uh thousands of uh relatives of
prisoners of war and uh it's sometimes
very difficult to uh find an information
about such persons as the war grinds on
a lack of information about those
prisoners and also missing civilians has
led to increasing frustration among
families I think it's a very difficult
situation because for a long time we
haven't received any information about
their loved ones and such a suspended
State affects them a lot it frustrates
them the information vacuum has also
allowed online frauders in Ukraine and
Russia to exploit families desperate for
news offering to sell information on
prisoners or even claiming to be able to
free them Valentina says she was
approached by someone online saying she
could pay to have her husband
released but I turned to Ukrainian
authorities and they said it was
impossible if it was really possible our
prisoners would have been home a long
time ago in the meantime she can only
endure a painful wait for any news Rob
McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer